this was a tragedy
that has now left two families broken
rana harris ali was just nine this was
him
hours before he drowned in one of
scotland's largest lakes
his mother and family friend muhammad
asim riaz
also died in loch lomond waris ali is
today mourning the loss of his son
and wife adina alejova in a statement on
his behalf
a close friend told sky news the family
is heartbroken
at the death of our charming young boy
in what was a tragic drowning accident
haris ali was the loveliest little boy
the trio died after somehow getting into
difficulty
at the northern tip of the loch on
saturday evening police scotland said
they were called to reports of concerns
for people's safety at around 6 40 p.m
but after a multi-agency operation they
were pronounced dead at the scene
it was a weekend of tragedy in scotland
six people in total died after drowning
in the country's waters
loch lomond national park said it was
undoubtedly the worst weekend
in their history in a tweet first
minister nicholas sturgeon
said this is heartbreaking my thoughts
and condolences
are with the loved ones of those who
have lost their lives in the water
over the past couple of days in scotland
we have some of the most beautiful locks
and rivers in the world
but if swimming in them please take care
it was a busy weekend for emergency
services across scotland
and police are warning people to
exercise extreme caution
when swimming in open water but the two
families from glasgow
who were enjoying a holiday in the hot
weather are now left mourning
after three deaths in what can be
dangerous waters
insane rasheed sky news glasgow